vous laissez en surface c'est pas un
problème cet aprem ça c'est du tas qui
part bien
ils sont souvent une dizaine petits et
grands pour venir parler biodiversité et
apprendre comment créer un beau jardin
l'idée c'est de pouvoir le mettre en
pratique pas uniquement faire les choses
sans
sans comprendre un petit peu comment ça
commence à fonctionner il va falloir
encore
là c'est sûr qu'à la fin de l'été s'est
fait d'accord on va pouvoir planter je
pense l'automne prochain un rendez-vous
pour combler un désir du retour à la
terre on a un petit peu
testé ça au premier confine branle un
peu par hasard et on a trouvé ça
intéressant de tester et puis de 8,2
mais très les mains dans la terre de
fabriquer soi même un petit bout de un
petit bout à manger des ateliers animés
par un jardiniers maraîchers de la
jardinerie de chevreuse tous les samedis
surtout destiné aux novices la plupart
du temps ce sont des débutants qui
viennent d'acquérir une maison ou qui
ont un jardin est d'accord il veut le
savoir comment entreprendre ce jardin
naturellement donc assez mal d'idées
reçues la permaculture est très à la
mode et on lit pas toujours la vérité
quatre modules sont proposés pour
compléter son savoir faire et sa
parcelle de terre